foreign
here was the question for the poll I
love it I said if you're a credit card
user what is the biggest thing holding
you back from getting rid of the cards
all right that's how I posed the
question I got tons of responses how
many people responded to you uh a few
hundred at least all right so this is
anecdotally this is science basically at
this yes that's right and I got a lot of
the natural responses that we've gotten
for 30 years right it's the points to
cash back the rewards I love to get my
free flight I need it to to book hotels
and rent cars and I got to keep up my
credit score so I can get a house and
get car loans and all these things but
the one that shocked me Ken uh-huh a lot
of people said fear fear of
just fear that's why I did I dug in I
did I dm'd I said tell me more about
that elaborate yes because that means a
lot of things to a lot of people some
people did admit they said hey this is a
safety blanket it's a crutch I I if
something goes wrong I know I'm covered
with my line of credit thanks to 28
interest from the credit card companies
what a blessing right but I wanted you
to address this idea of fear because
you've been leading a financial peace
class virtually and this has come up a
lot yeah when it comes to the thousand
dollar emergency fund scares me I can't
cut up the card because what if what if
what if right there's so much fear and
some of it stems from their childhood
they told me hey I grew up poor we grew
up not having money oh we grew up or if
one paycheck didn't show up we were
screwed yeah and so I have a lot of
empathy for those that have that fear
but you've talked a lot about this on
your show whether it's career or money
fear is holding people back in a whole
lot of ways yeah well a couple things on
that most of the time if you actually
look at the data the things that we
worry about which is another placeholder
for fear you know because I think fear
is defined as I'm worried that something
bad is going to happen I just think
that's the way I define fear and I think
that's really true and so most of the
time the things we worry about rarely
happen so let's just that's just some
basic psychology study right there where
they like the things we worry about most
of the time never actually happen so
there's that the second thing is is that
people are afraid
that they're going to be destitute
broke so far behind the eight ball that
they never recovered that they forget
that the credit card is going to hit
them for 28 percent versus and let's
give you a real life example let's say
an HVAC system goes out okay because
this is one of the things that popped up
on our FPU class
I've got an old HVAC system I'm gonna
have to replace it it's on its last leg
I don't want to be in the house all
summer in sweltering heat not be able to
sleep and by the way I get all that I
don't minimize any of that it's like
yeah I get it all right so they think
the credit card then is the safety net
so if we have to put eight grand into an
HVAC system or six grand or whatever it
is
well we put it on the credit card no
problem but now we're paying 28 interest
as opposed to going the HVAC company and
going hey here's my situation
here's my financials
I need this HVAC system we're stuck so
we either are with ceiling fans and you
know and just fans or whatever we're
gonna or we've or replace it let's say
it's in the winter time and you go to
the HVAC company and go listen
I can cash flow this
and I will cash flow it you know and
just having a human conversation with
somebody yeah but just relying on the
credit card puts you in more stress and
more problems because while you take
care of the immediate need
you're stuck with it for a long time and
so I think it depends George on the
specific fear but a lot of people just
feel like I'm not going to be able to be
comfortable and take care of my life and
uh Les who is on with me I want to refu
coaches we talked about
AC going in my car one time it went and
this is when we first lived here in
Nashville the first time and we were
working the baby steps
and I couldn't afford like I could have
but I didn't want to stop the momentum
so George I got up earlier and drove
into the office an hour earlier
so that I wasn't sweating profusely to
get into the office at the end of the
day it didn't matter I was going home
and then one day I was driving home
George
and insult to injury I came up to a
stoplight it was almost like uh the debt
gods were trying to embarrass me I got
no AC I'm sweating hair all over the
place because the windows are down
and that I don't know what you call that
your roof liner inside the car just all
of a sudden detached out of nowhere and
it was sitting on top of my head I felt
it at a stoplight I look up and this and
you know how embarrassing that is yeah
because you think that everyone at the
stoplight is going look at this loser
over there it's a hundred degrees in
Nashville he's got the roof interior
carpet hanging on his head I went home
was so mad I got the staple gun out of
the uh out of the storage
that's therapeutic right there two
Staples in the top took care of that
problem and cost me nothing wow but what
are you afraid of yeah you afraid of
being embarrassed at the stoplight I get
it that's a good question is you know a
lot of people like to they're very
optimistic when it comes to their own
stupidity they're they're going yeah
we'll pay it out we're gonna open the
card it'll be great they're very
optimistic when it comes to justifying
their spending habits their decisions
and very pessimistic when it comes to
following a proven plan where they go
yeah having a thousand bucks is scary
and you should be scared and the problem
is when you have the credit card still
there you have a false sense of security
yes you have a false sense of comfort
and the book The Comfort crisis you guys
have been talking about this a lot with
Dave I think we're too comfortable I
think part of the reason America is
where it is today yeah broke in debt
anxious miserable stressed is because
we're aiming for comfort and convenience
and the easiest path the path of least
resistance the most convenient path
instead of going
dang it I really gotta work that extra
job to get out of debt even faster and
that's what I love about baby step one I
don't love that you're scared to death
but I love that it puts a fire under you
to go I wasn't safe ever I had the
illusion of safety that's right and then
once you have the emergency fund and
baby step three you got out of debt you
don't need the credit card like but you
don't understand that mentality of what
if because I don't think that they've
been taught this so I think this is a I
want to tee you up to teach on this
let's say that the thing happens we've
got a thousand dollars in baby step one
but then a seven or eight or ten
thousand dollar or even a 1500 expense
they go it's not enough Ken yeah but my
point is they're all worried about this
big thing above and beyond a thousand
dollars yeah what do you teach what
would you tell them if you're sitting
one-on-one with him and go okay this is
seven eight thousand you only got a
thousand what are their options well
number one we say pause the baby steps
right if you've got kind of a storm and
in that case we're gonna we're gonna pay
all the minimums on the debt so we're
going to cover the basic bills
everything else all the luxuries
throughout the window right now because
we got to sell everything we can work as
much as we can to find that Gap to make
that margin once you've got that expense
covered or back on track we're attacking
the debt and in most situations uh I've
seen they end up not needing the full
thousand or they pause it and they end
up cash flowing it and make sure you
have the right Insurance in place this
is something we teach because most
emergencies you know Health Emergency
you're gonna have up to your deductible
and then you're covered right and you
get auto insurance make sure you've got
the right coverage there these kinds of
things help me sleep at night to make
sure that I'm covered in case of
something crazy happening but a lot of
times it's psychological and it's them
justifying why they want to keep the
card around George you know the old
phase where there's a all there's a way
in other words it means you know if I'm
willing to figure it out I'll find a way
do you poke holes in that when it comes
to this very scenario or do you believe
that that holds true I'll find a way to
not use a credit card I'll find a way to
pay it off I'll find a way but I'm not
going to use a credit card for an
emergency well when you take debt off
the table if you just in your mind
pretend and go credit cards are not an
option debt is not an option what would
I do if this was the 1930s and debt
wasn't marketed as heavily as it is
today what would I do you'd go all right
I'm gonna go sell some stuff I'm gonna
get the side job I'm going to cut down
all my expenses to Bare Bones I'm going
to work out a plan a payment plan with
the HVAC guy to pay this thing off and
we're going to figure it out
so my challenge to everyone out there is
could you live 90 days without using
your credit card put it in ice in the
freezer lock it up somewhere stick to a
debit card in cash
for 90 days and DM me if you're gonna do
this challenge I want to report back 90
days from now and see how it changes you
financially spiritually emotionally if
it gets you further down the line to
where you want to be financially wow I
love that George good challenge at
George Campbell on the ground right
there with a K don't wear it out and if
you're over the age of 50 that means
Instagram thank you for that caveat